[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to this very special
mashup edition of peak prosperity and
the dark horse podcast this is my good
friend chris martinson i should say dr
chris martinson and for those of you who
don't know me i am dr brett weinstein
this is an experiment that we are
running here we are streaming to both of
our channels chris and i have come to
know each other
over recent months and it is one of
those delightful discoveries i won't
speak for him but i will say for me that
to find someone else who has arrived in
a similar position having traveled a
very different path is an extremely
rewarding and fascinating experience
chris and i have talked a great deal
not in public and
the last time we did
we were left with a strong impression
that probably people would benefit from
hearing what two people who see a
similar picture surrounding the collapse
of the public health narrative and the
coming storm what we sound like to each
other as we attempt to make sense of the
world and figure out what it is we're
supposed to do now
so i don't know if i should be welcoming
you chris or what since we're both on
each other's channel but it's good to
see you buddy
hey chris
i'm being told that there is some
technical problem that is preventing
people from hearing you and i'm thinking
that's a bad thing
right for one thing it makes me sound
like i'm talking to myself which
is an indication of a possibly organic
disorder which i don't have but um
anyway i know that so
we're going to try to fix this all right
okay well chris
this puts us in a terribly awkward
situation because you said a bunch of uh
lovely and
incredibly cogent things and uh maybe
repeating them would be a good idea
well what i was i'd be happy to repeat
them um
it's fabulous to be here with you and i
know that you and i have had some
incredibly good conversations that
i found gratifying heartwarming
reassuring because
as you mentioned you and i have walked
very different paths and and we've
arrived at a similar sort of set of
conclusions and that means a lot to me
because
if a hundred people walk a single path
and get somewhere that's not as relevant
to me as if three people
using different tools different things
different approaches come and and have
that
conciliance of coming towards that point
that that makes sense so i found in this
whole covet experience there aren't that
many people who've managed to
keep their head about them be able to
shift with the data as it's been
unfolding
to not only understand what's happening
with cobit itself but but maybe to
understand that there's something else
working here and so yeah our
conversations have been fantastic and
i'm really excited to be bringing this
out to more people because i think it's
a valuable conversation to be had in
public
it is a very valuable conversation i
know that you and i are also both hoping
um
that i don't know i don't want to
describe it as a team but the people who
are
listening to each of our channels and
coming to make sense of the world
through them will recognize that they
are a great deal stronger than they had
understood
because there are so many more of us and
the fact that your
work does not show up frequently inside
the circles that i travel is a
fascinating fact to me i can't imagine
why a perspective that is a similar
wouldn't be ever present and you know so
i've had to tune in to you actively i'm
hoping that my
my listeners will realize what that
implies i mean the most obvious thing
is that they should most certainly go
and
they should follow you on twitter they
should find your youtube channel and
they should discover that there's a
large community of people who has a
similar perspective that was built with
uh different tools and you know that's
that couldn't possibly be better news so
i hope they will i will hope they will
do that and i hope your listeners will
come find me and come find my listeners
and that that uh
that big bump in capacity uh will be
something we benefit from from here on
out
this is my theme for 2022 it's bringing
bringing these different groups together
as much as possible and i i don't have a
good explanation for why
you're you we we we've sort of like
bumped around in different territory
without more overlap is this is it just
that's just how it is is is there some
active sort of sheep dogging by the big
tech media to keep people away from each
other um i mean i certainly have some
evidence that that i i don't have the
same easy free run in social media that
say the kardashians do but i don't want
to ascribe it all to that so i don't
know it's kind of been a it's an
interesting phenomenon yep um
it's a head scratcher
um all right so let's just say what
we're shooting for here is to kind of
carve out a a new mode where um we
talk between our two different uh but
aligned perspectives and we get people
on board with what that sounds like and
hash out differences that we have that's
the most productive thing that we can do
if we can spot things that we haven't
come to agreement on
if this works i think at some level
it is your your channel being peak
prosperity mind being dark horse it will
be an exercise in dark prosperity and if
we screw it up i feel certain it will be
peak horse
um
give it well let's go with dark brother
yeah oh i'm definitely definitely
shooting
for the dark prosperity
all right so um let's uh let's get to
some of the heart of the matter
here so people know really what the
topic of discussion is
i think we are in
almost undeniably
suddenly a new phase with respect to
covid
right omicron threw a curveball
to
the uh the stewards of our perspective
and they fumbled it all right i've just
mixed sports metaphors but let's go with
it
they
did not switch gears and recognize that
even if they were inclined to continue
deploying the exact same prescription
that they had been on for delta and the
previous variants that the public was
going to detect that as an error because
omicron
certainly demands a different approach
so their
the fact that the approach that they had
deployed over delta and the other
variants made no sense whatsoever was
suddenly validated by the fact that they
made even less sense against omicron
and this has forced
a lot of pivoting it has forced a lot of
acknowledgement of things that you and i
and our friends have been saying for
many months
and it has effectively caused the
narrative that they had so carefully
constructed to begin to collapse and we
now see things like mandates being
withdrawn around the world we see it
being done at the level of corporations
that say we're no longer going to
enforce this on our employees we see
nations backing away from them
and that's all very good news
but again
i think a lot of
people who have been paying attention
and maybe have paid a high price for
being on the unpopular side of this
discussion
are thinking well thank god it's finally
over and my sense is
something is over
but something else is about to begin and
i think people need to see it clearly so
it doesn't catch them off guard
um do you see something similar
unfortunately i do you know i i guess my
background where i started with this um
kind of a long origin story but it
really began with with the first foray
into iraq
um
and that was back in 2002 i guess
so there was all these ideas of weapons
of mass destruction and and um i got
well i guess that's the second one the
first one was a poppy bush but i mean
this was this was that that piece under
george w
and
i had
gone into because i'm this kind of guy i
went into the data and i found out
this doesn't make sense you know they
don't they couldn't possibly have what
colin powell was saying they had and so
um i went out and organized a protest
march in in mystic connecticut where i
was living at the time
and i quit and we had i think 17 million
people around the world rose up and said
let's not do this let's not go to war
and and
the agenda just
went right along anyway as if people
didn't matter as if voices didn't matter
as if you know none of it mattered and
so so
i'm seeing i see the same strains today
right this it's the same playbook in
essence where there's a
an agenda
and it's out of step with the narrative
so the narrative omicron just shredded
the coveted narrative just broke it
right beautifully just smashed it to
smithereens
and just yesterday i think it was
rachelle wolinski of the cdc was saying
well what we really need to do is pivot
and be sure that everybody understands
that everybody needs a
booster right i i don't know how to make
sense of of that um because what she's
doing is she's clinging to an agenda
that's clearly broken
and a narrative that was really failing
all on its own anyway even without
omicron but it's really really failing
under omicron
and so it speaks to this idea of what's
next that you brought up which is that
my experience watching
the iraq war unfold was that
these people when they proved to be
wrong
they never they never go oops are bad
you know where was the we got the
mission accomplished we never got the
hey we're so sorry it turns out there
never wore weapons of mass destruction
here's some consequences for the people
who
architected that bald face lie right
that didn't happen instead we just
rolled from one thing to the next so so
i agree with you this once this agenda
narrative is over i think what we have
to be alert for
is the next one that they're gonna pop
out they and i is is there a single they
in this story
i don't really know but i mean
we always trip over this sort of thing
because there clearly is
a they
but the they has definite has components
right there's clearly you know you can
see in the emails that there was a they
orchestrating the loudly cover-up right
and it involved many of the names who
were prominent in the the phony public
uh face that was put forward
there's also a they that involves lots
of
surrogates in the media many of whom
probably have no idea what they're doing
uh and are just
you know ambitious in the in the
negative sense of that term where they
are
vying to curry favor with power and to
get ahead and then there is a vast
brigade
of useful idiots and
i would say in wallensky's case
i have the sense that
she does not know
where she is and what she is doing she
is a true believer in something or
someone
and
uh
it's breathtaking to watch her hold on
as the narrative crumbles around her
um it's clearly
it's not a good look i gotta say it does
not look like a wise person trying to
scramble for higher ground it looks like
a person uh who was dispensable to
whatever the they is
yeah i would agree i don't i don't put
her up on the top shelf of his anus
she's
she's she she's clearly a a useful
uh front for it but not even all that
that good at her job so i actually
cringe and i feel bad for her from time
to time because i think it's clear she's
way out of her depth and doesn't i don't
know that she really understands the
game that she's upon in
so she plays it badly um
and and with not a lot of sophistication
uh you know the next shelf up certainly
we've got vouchee he's a very skilled
player of whatever the game is um but
even there i'm not sure that we're
looking at the
the true face of the they in this story
it feels
the horsepower that was involved to get
this whole
narrative off the ground was
breathtaking to me i'm a very
deep student of this when i watched
every single european country with the
exception of sweden which is an odd
story here i watched israel i watched
canada i watched new zealand canada
united states all fall into lockstep
around this one narrative
that's power right even even as india
was like nah no thanks we'll do it kind
of different for most of it not kerala
but most of india was like yeah we got
this bangladesh africa indonesia like
everybody was kind of doing it a little
different with stunning success in some
of those locales and we just kept going
um across a lot of different cultures i
don't think of europe as one so well let
me uh let me
this is not something i've talked about
with anybody it's just sort of a thought
that was running around in my head
there's some sort of narrative
clearly
not organic that was constructed that
its purpose was to
lead people to a particular set of
behaviors and beliefs now that many
people i think have very clearly
mistakenly understood it to be noble
lies
but i don't believe it could be i don't
believe it could possibly be as far off
the mark as it is if it was a mistake
but what i see
is a kind of
proximity effect
it's like fouchy is a megaphone
broadcasting
this message
and the closer you are to fouchy the
more distorted your
civilization has
has been around covet so it's like
we are the epicenter of confusion
and europe is very thoroughly confused
right but as you get farther from fouchy
you begin to see experiments in reason
and you see them in the oddest places
you do see them in africa you see them
in indonesia you see them in japan right
you do see them in mexico you see them
in south america and
that is interesting because in in some
sense what it means is whatever this
game is
it's hurting us worst because
the they
is
closest to us it has the best access to
our minds and it is unhooked reason most
effectively right here right
um
and that is an amazing fact right like
once again we're going to end
up with
worse access i mean just the simple fact
that medications that we know work have
been made scarce and in other parts of
the world it was hard to make them
scarce and less important that they be
made scarce and so people actually have
them right that is an amazing inversion
of the usual this is the opposite of
privilege
is what it is
yeah that's it right go ahead yeah
no that's a great point so
um
you know i've uh i just tested positive
for covet a few days ago um i've had
some symptoms i've had this conversation
with people who said so if it gets bad
are you going to the hospital i'm like
no no
like you want to talk about an inversion
of privilege i'm actually first time in
my life legit scared to go to the
hospital because i checked my local
hospital is all about rendezvous and
ventilators they are
they are stuck in something that
the the most third world nation you
could find wouldn't dream of doing
because they have access to a better
route of they they know the data all
says that is the wrong thing to do and
it's still being done and plus if i get
pulled into that system
my partner evie can't come with me
there's nobody there to advocate for me
you get you get sucked into this place
where you have no rights anymore not
even the right to
determine what treatments you want it's
it's bizarre and
i'm not sure if it's always been that
way or if cove had made it worse or
something new arose but that's that's
it's legitimate bret this is a weird
place for me to be i would not go to the
hospital it'd be my last right i have
man this is one of these places we've
never had this conversation i have
exactly the same sense is that at this
moment i mean this is a weird thing to
say right the hospital has a tremendous
number of very important tools it can
deploy on your behalf
but i actually think we are worse off in
that context i am probably in a better
position if i come down let's say it's
kovid right and i get a bad case and i'm
in jeopardy
i am probably better off with
pierre cory on the phone telling me what
i should do than a hospital full of
tools and experts going by the narrative
and that's a frightening place to have
landed
that is not a good sign that is a sign
things are desperately off
and
i mean it's also you know i thought a
lot because various people i guess most
recently
it's been um
wow i'm blanking on his name which is
probably a good idea howard stern right
howard stern was mouthing off about how
the unvaccinated should not be granted
access
to hospitals and you know there was a
part of me that months ago was thinking
all right
i'll take that deal right
if i am making a decision to forgo the
vaccine
i am willing
to endure the consequences but then i
realized something you know what
i'm not in a generous mood about this
point and the reason is but you robbed
me of all of the tools that i would use
if you want to make a deal with me that
says look you can do whatever you want
but you can't make use of our hospital
if our hospital
is advising you to take a vaccine that
you won't that's a deal i would make but
then i get access to all of the other
stuff right i get access to the things
that have been deployed around the world
that we know work the things that
doctors have figured out how to deploy
that they are saving patients at an
amazing right i get access to those
things yeah i won't go to the hospital
for covet for sure now what you and i
are talking about is actually probably i
don't want to go to the hospital anyway
because they might give me rem desevere
right
that's counterproductive
so
yeah and i should actually uh we
i screwed up it was me entirely um
if people don't know who you are where
your expertise comes from
um could you tell them a little bit
about your background
sure um
my i got a phd in path from the
department of pathology with a
sub-specialty was toxicology actually i
went into a toxicology program but they
don't have a department of toxicology
duke so it's housed under pathology so
my phd
from duke is in pathology
and the way that program works is the
first two years is with all the medical
students uh and then
years three and four they put the white
coats and the stethoscopes on and i went
into the lab so i was doing surgical
pathology histology things like that so
uh got a standard pathology training and
then did a couple of years of postdoc
very basic cell biological work in the
department of cell biology after that um
neurotoxicology is where i started to
focus down
so a lot of time behind a microscope
looking at you know live cells which is
the most magic thing ever we could have
a conversation about that sometime
then after that experience
i went and got a they have a one-year
mba program at cornell so i got an mba
and then i went off and worked first
first job out of that was actually at
pfizer in department of corporate
finance down in groton connecticut
then one thing led to another uh later i
was a vice president of a company called
saic doing
basically body shopping um uh consulting
back into the pharma business i just
left and
then after that uh i left and started a
blog um so nobody should ask me for
career advice i'm just wrong guy
but that blog was my mission and i was
talking about um the housing bubble at
that point in time i had just come
across peak oil as a concept i started
to work things and i really took a full
three year sabbatical and created
something called the crash course which
is now 28
video chapters that connect economy
energy environment sort of at a systems
level uh very high level so i'm not an
expert in any one of those but i know
enough about each to have this
synthesized view that says we need to
look at all of this in context if we
want to have a chance of understanding
where the puck is going to be in this
story um so yeah where the [ __ ] is it so
i guess
unfortunately it's on some really thin
ice right now yeah so all right this is
great and this also gives a window into
why
you and i find so much analogy between
our perspectives which is
being a generalist is different and
doing synthesis is different and one of
the things that has absolutely unhooked
reason from most of the intelligentsia
is that they actually think that there
is a method to go to a place called the
literature and look at something they
call the data and derive from it a
description of what is taking place and
the answer is
wouldn't it be lovely if that were true
but it isn't right this is a complex
dynamic phenomenon that is being
analyzed by a
corrupt and in many ways feeble academic
structure
and what it comes up with
doesn't add up so what you need is a
toolkit that allows you to borrow from
various different disciplines borrow
from various different
vantage points
to be able to put together the best
explanation for the phenomena that you
can be pretty certain are actually real
right
that's a whole different game than
sitting down at you know some data and
drawing a conclusion
it's not that it doesn't involve data
but you have to understand how to weight
it you have to understand what
experiment was actually run and
therefore what the data actually imply
and this is not something that people
are in general used to so most people
have
punted and what they've done is they've
said here's a voice that sounds good to
me i'm just going to go with what they
said right and if it's eric topel you're
cooked
right you're just cooked you just signed
up for nonsense and
in any case very interesting that you
have these specialties i'm especially
delighted to hear things like toxicology
and pathology in there right these are
windows in that very few people
have right especially toxicology you you
lived through the madness surrounding
claims about ivermectin as a
toxicologist he was in a position to say
what the reality there was um so you
know it's it's an amazing tool kit and
the generalist approach is
absolutely crushing
the the narrow specialist what did the
data say approach
um in this pandemic
you know we are the sum of our trainings
to a point i mean i was born a certain
way i think that's part of it but but
the pathology training you know it's all
statistics somebody says hey my uncle
smokes four packs a day is he gonna get
lung cancer and you know the answer is
maybe right and here's some odds and and
so we were very statistically trained
but more than that when you have a slice
of of tissue
and you're trying to determine the
degree of dysplasia or or you know the
abnormal changes in cells like is it
fully cancerous there's a whole sweep
and series of changes and it's it's very
subjective if you're i mean i know
they've got machines that are starting
to hone in on it getting better but when
i was there like you had to really use
your best interpretation and there were
associated changes it wasn't just the
cells themselves that you're looking at
it was the ones around them it took a
lot of
it's sort of educated guesswork as it
were and the and the more
more experience you have with it the
better you get but what i learned from
it was that there's no there's no right
or wrong there's no crisp line ever that
says
cancerous not cancerous you know there's
this whole gradation and then there's a
different even if it is cancerous
there's a whole gradation of how it's
going to present and how malignant it's
going to be and all of that so it's i
think through all of that and and my
background as a scientist you know i was
in the biological sciences you can run
in about six months you can go from
the what's known to the edge of what's
known in any particular branch of
biology and start doing really cool
research right at the front here and
there are very few people at the
frontier who have the right toolkit for
it but i i want to correct you
i'm going to correct you in a way that i
feel certain you're going to agree with
right you said it's educated guesswork
and i know that that calls up exactly
the wrong image in people's minds
because what it really is is something
like
a process an iterated process of
self-educating guesswork
right the point is somebody who does
this well
walks into a situation in which they
know they are not expert and they begin
to try to make sense of patterns that
they can detect and the point is okay
here's what i think i see
here's what
would be true if i am correct and then
i'm going to go look and i'm going to do
an honest job of saying well did i get
it and the point is to the extent that
you keep predicting things then your
model is pretty good at the point your
model stops predicting things it isn't
and then the question is well what would
have to be true for my model to be
failing in this case oh
now i see it and so you know every
cancer is its own phenomenon as as you
know better than i do
a
a forest is a
chaotic environment right in order to
make sense of any such phenomenon you
have to have this toolkit in which the
point is you know that you walk in with
near total ignorance
and the way you walk out with something
much better than the near total
ignorance that you walked in with is an
iterated process of educating yourself
and if you have a taste for it you know
it's a tremendous amount of fun
if you don't know where to start then
it's like well i don't like any of this
chaos maybe i'll go look at a paper and
it will tell me what to think you know
and
that's just not a functional mode
yeah no i i agree with that and um and
to get back to to the uh i think
something we share is is uh
i i have i i read a lot of books i have
a special shelf where those the only
books on that shelf there's something
they all share and that is they changed
how i thought
right i just i know it the minute i read
it doesn't have to be the whole
book in the middle of a perfect
paragraph but it fundamentally changed
how i saw the world that's what i value
most highly i love having my mind
changed and opened uh and so that's just
an attribute i don't know if i was born
with it or it was a nurture thing i
don't know
but it's certainly uh
it's like i love i loved what i was able
to learn through covet i was offended by
the people who are trying to shut down
that open inquiry and i was really i
loved all the people i found who were
the open you know explorers out there
you're among them and pierre cory you
mentioned a name but we found out in
this whole thing like who was legit
honestly curious and open-minded and
that
is amazing to me because
i trust you now
i trust pierre i have about 20 people
sort of in that bucket some of them i've
never met i was supposed to meet him
this weekend in dc but covet
but i trust them more than people i've
known my whole life
in other circumstances so it's
it's been a that's been a good thing oh
it's been a great thing right now i mean
it's
more than ample
uh compensation for the tragedy of all
of the people that you wanted to be good
at this who turned out to be terrible
and then got vicious
right so anyway all of the wonderful
people that we have discovered who are
actually have a taste for this are good
at it are you know open to being wrong
and fixing their model because that's
the point um that's been a delightful
discovery and i have described it to my
viewers as
an upgrade a very painful upgrade
process that happens any time you run
into us a situation this charged because
people will disappoint you right and
left and then suddenly you'll learn
about people you didn't know existed who
are actually courageous and highly
capable and it's like okay well yeah
i'll make it that trade anytime right
disappoint me go away and then i meet
someone and i say well all right i've
just you know i've just picked up this
person who was much more capable and
frankly somebody that if you land in a
foxhole with them you don't have to
worry that they're going to panic
um
yeah well
are we a foxhole
we're in a modern voxel yeah i i
absolutely i absolutely believe this and
most people just aren't up to it
um
it's a pretty big uh stretch right i
mean it's it's
to really
i wonder if i if i even have my arms
fully around exactly what's going on but
you know so again from my background as
a person who's a biologist fundamentally
looking at whole system biology meanings
at least at this whole cell level um is
is where a lot of my research was done
i understand intimately the role of
energy and resources and you know you
either
remembered to plate your cells out with
appropriate levels of medium and glucose
or you didn't you know and if you didn't
they would all ball up and get very
simple and very unhappy looking and i
understand where we are as a species
in this story and so that's a frame i
bring to this and i'm open to all the
other ones too but my frame says
we're at a really critical moment in our
species history
i think people are detecting that on
many different levels but of course you
can't even open up the newspaper or
online news source without finding out
there's something not quite right with
microplastics and where'd the fish go
and what's up with the insects and
can we really suck this aquifer down at
six percent a year when it takes ten
thousand years to recharge and on and on
and on right and and
from that kova then becomes the backdrop
which says look we couldn't even discuss
ivermectin without like losing the plot
line how are we going to manage
disappearing
ecosystem services that we haven't even
properly mapped yet let alone begun to
appreciate this this is such a beautiful
point right if you are going to be
bewildered by a campaign as transparent
as the i don't know the great horse
dewormer
gunshot victim yes debacle if you're
going to be fooled by that you know
you're not going to get the question of
pesticides and its implication right
you're not going to be able to navigate
the question of how does
um you know a mrna
lipid nano particle vaccine compare to a
live attenuated virus you know
you just don't have the tools right
you're easily fooled and it's one thing
to know that and to say hey look
i'm out it's another thing to think you
do get it and
we've been
uh i don't know we've been
quite buffeted by many many people who
pretended to have good tools and just
just didn't
but i want to switch us switch gears a
little bit here and we have been so far
talking kind of generally about
where we're going you said you don't
you're not you don't quite have your
arms around where we are and i would say
actually i think that this is sort of
uh
the primary entrance requirement to the
adult discussion
right if you're really paying attention
to what's going on
you you know that you don't know where
we are right there are possibilities you
may have a sense that it's this and not
that you can say certain things aren't
likely to be true but i don't know
anybody right the most informed people
in the world who are not on the inside
don't know what this is about and
therefore don't know
what it is that will be
protected and obscured in this phase
where we go from
the public health narrative collapsing
on the public health authorities to
whatever they're going to do in the
great scramble
to come
and i fear
that because people have the sort of
sense of relief that you know i mean i
don't know what you've seen you're
you're out east you're in uh
massachusetts is that right
so i'm out here in oregon we're living
physically very different uh existences
among
people who aren't connected
what i'm watching is
omicron
completely overwhelmed
even the false impression that control
was possible
and
it
caused everybody to kind of surrender
and they just stopped taking covet
seriously and
that was interesting and they frankly
with omicron
it's probably the right approach for
many reasons because a you're not going
to control it with masks right you're
not going to control it with masks
boosters make less than no sense given
the evidence of
the vaccinated being so very vulnerable
to
contracting and transmitting omicron
but in any case people just sort of
i think they breathed a sigh of relief
and moved on and the problem is
we are dealing with
a
self-inflicted wound
covid appears to be a self-inflicted
wound of
unprecedented scale
right two years of turning the entire
world upside down
over
a virus that appears to have been
enhanced
and then escaped
now that is an amazing error to have
made and the costs will never be fully
understood
right the costs are absolutely
gigantic so it stands to reason that our
top priority ought to be figuring out
exactly what happened
and building the best protections we can
to make sure nothing like this ever
happens again because frankly as
bad and unprecedented as it was it could
have been worse
so
then we are left with the question of
well what should happen now and
my increasingly i am preoccupied
with the way that those who did this
are going to escape being
uh properly
um
revealed
and the reforms that are necessary will
be avoided because of course this was
whatever its fundamental nature
this was
um the mother of all opportunities for
certain people right the amount of
wealth that was generated on the back of
kovid the amount of power that was
concentrated the amount of progress that
tyrants have made in getting us to
surrender our rights and getting used to
the idea that that's a normal thing to
do
right these were spectacular changes and
they are now going to do everything in
their power
to avoid us understanding what happened
so that they can do it again and
we must stop that but that involves
recognizing where we are this is not the
end it might be the end of covid it
might be that another variant pops up
and returns us to some place or takes us
someplace new those are live
possibilities you can tell me if you see
reasons to think they aren't
but at the level of what happens to
society which frankly
i think you'll agree is much more
dangerous than what happens to us as a
result of this particular virus
we are still
in grave jeopardy and the game is only
just beginning
thank you i love having this
conversation i've been so
um
it was may of 2020 when i put out a
first video i was like this thing kind
of looks like it came from a lab right
and i i was using the genetic
information on it in particular the pra
fur and cleavage site i was like that's
that's weird
and i couldn't find any other nearby
viruses that that had that particular
sequence you know so it had to have
gotten it from somewhere and so there
wasn't a a molecular biological or
evolutionary
explanation for it that made sense so
you weigh the evidence and i was like
pretty sure this came from a lab right
so i was a conspiracy theorist for a
full year in the press and then somehow
that story changed one day then all of a
sudden it was okay to talk about it and
that was interesting watching the
narrative control but i agree with you
completely that
if we don't not only find out how it
arose and how it got to escape
not only find the people who were
responsible for that find out if they
broke any laws or rules right if we
don't do that
they've just learned oh we can get away
with this and when people have no
consequences and they learn they can get
away with something they'll do it again
particularly if they get to make
trillions of dollars and you know secure
vast new rights and powers and things
like that so
i think it's really troubling that my
culture in the united states that our
press is yeah they sort of weakly sort
of look at this lab leak thing but
they're not really on it it's like they
don't have an interest in finding out
why or how that might have happened and
i i think that's an error a big error
because it'll just happen again that's
not that's not a pro that's that's about
that's not a prediction in the sense
that i'm trying to tell you something in
the future that's uncertain that's like
saying if i let go of a hammer it's
going to fall to the ground i don't
think it's an error
and i don't want to describe it in
overly deliberate terms because i think
a lot of this functions
subconsciously that people detect that
there is something desired from them and
they do it and it rewards them and they
don't exactly know why why they were
invited to do it but
the the whole idea
that
the you know the horses are out of the
barn
why are we so concerned with the origin
yes it's kind of interesting it would be
nice if we knew someday what happened
but what does it change this is
very wrong on two fronts
i mean for one thing
if it did come from a lab and it seems
almost certain that it did we have a
right to know the protocols that
generated it which might well tell us
something useful about how to address it
and
the idea that anybody has the right to
say
no
you won't find anything interesting
there is
preposterous but what i really think is
happening is that a lot of people who
weren't ahead and who didn't suffer the
stigma of
saying hey
this looks like a lab leak it's not
making me happy to say it but it looks
like one
people who didn't do that and people who
said terrible things about folks like us
who did
are
signaling to power
that effectively they're advertising a
willingness to embrace amnesty for the
lab leak all right i'm not going to go
after this and the point is i see a
negotiation unfolding in the world at
the moment and the negotiation involves
people
you know
the public is going to want an
explanation of how the public health
authorities
got it so wrong
and so there's a scramble
to fill that need but the point is the
people who got this so wrong are
connected to the most powerful forces in
the world
and so they get some say in who they
have to confess to and how much they
have to confess and what they want to do
is confess enough that it is satisfying
and not so much that anything changes
and i i really think that this is what
happens next right they are bargaining
with the middle ground those who got it
wrong are going to move in the direction
of right but the whole idea is to save
the
elite rent seekers who at the very least
took merciless advantage of the
situation from the reckoning that would
be natural and from the reforms that
would plug the leak
so
yeah i
the lab leak is a good model because we
won that battle for the most part early
and we can say what happened right there
was a mad scramble amongst people who
had gotten lab leak wrong to become the
new voices of reason who acknowledged
that there was a lab leak and were able
to point to indications that they may
have left that possibility open before
but anything was better than going to
the people who said actually you have no
idea how high the chances are
and how much the evidence there is and
the fact that there is exactly zero
evidence pointing in the other direction
and you know you ought to be thinking
about this
so yeah i i see a kind of de facto
negotiation and i wish there was some
way to describe it so that people did
not hear it as the allegation of a
smoke-filled room in which people are
actually talking because that's not the
kind of negotiation it is
right it's an as if negotiation
you know there's um
i agree with that i agree with that
there's
so there was a a
a chart in a book that showed um and
this was by ralph barrack and and it
showed this is pretty covet but it
showed
all the things that we we humans have
been doing with um corona viruses and so
the first time that we'd taken a chimera
and taken a piece off of one and put it
in and made it more effective in an
animal model was 1998
and um
there might have been earlier stuff but
that's the first publication on this
chart and then there's like all these
seminal things people are doing
including by 2002 ralph barrack had
figured out how to do the noseem inserts
so that you could actually build an
entire viral construct without anybody
being able to detect that it had been
through a lab he got a patent on that it
was 2003 when sars broke out so prior to
to sars we
never had a pandemic coronavirus
prior to humans monkeying around trying
to make them more infectious we'd never
had one so i might my questioning about
this whole thing goes back a long way
now um
and
so you then you watch the mers thing
come out and you watch this thing come
out
soros cov2
it's clearly
been manipulated and i you know i have a
whole story about omicron too which
looks even more manipulated it's pretty
obvious
so i think we have to have that
conversation though because
i don't know that we
it's pretty clear that whether people
meant well they had a white hat sort of
a reason they thought that this was
going to advance knowledge so that we
could learn things that would be
important i think what's missing in that
is the hubris is has overshadowed this
idea that even
30 000 tiny strings of letters which
we'll call the rna code of this
particular virus is too complicated for
us to understand or manage like it just
did wildly complex things inside the
human body when it got in there i don't
know if you saw this breath but there
was a study that showed that not only is
this 38 you know kilo bits of
information
come forward and enter a cell and do all
this stuff but it has little proteins
that it shuttles into the nucleus to
turn certain genes on and off it's just
so ridiculously complex but there are
people who think we can control that and
learn from that and and fiddle with that
um so in essence what we're dealing with
with sarsko v2 now is humans as a
species were having to adjust to
a virus that didn't go through the
normal
call it normal
pathways so it got a big sudden jump in
evolution and that's not a normal
condition so we're gonna we're gonna
learn some things about this and i don't
think we're over
yet in just in learning some things
there might be things we discover in
three four five years like real
long-haul coveted we don't know we
we don't know and that's what bothers me
is that these people who did this brett
they they still are operating with that
sort of hubris and impunity that says
well even if it escaped we can do better
next time but i don't
i think we're jeff goldblum's character
in jurassic park you know yeah or the
fly it's like just because you can
just because you can do something
doesn't mean we should so this is uh
this is a battle
that
i'm going to avoid ranting but this is a
battle that
has been going on forever and that
animated me when i was a graduate
student right because
the the lab that i was in
was actually a lab of
effectively refugees from the rest of
the biology department these are people
who understood the power of selection
and so you know the funny thing is i
graduated having come from the the um
the entomology lab
i'm not an entomologist i studied bats
and most of the people in that lab under
dick alexander didn't study bugs
they studied dolphins and birds and
every other thing right
and the reason was that that was the
place where people who understood the
power of selection had gathered because
it wasn't all that hospitable anywhere
else in the department right the
ecologists by and large didn't get it
right the the cellular molecular people
didn't get it
and so the point is look
you don't you believe
in the evolutionary story in the
textbook which is a feeble cartoon
compared to the real thing right the
idea that you think you know anything
about the virus that you've created when
what you've really done is put something
on the foothill of some mountain range
you don't know anything about and what
you do know is that it's got a program
for climbing right it's going to become
something it's not under your control
the question is what niche did you just
bring it to
and
we can there's a perfectly good example
of this
hawaii is a tropical
uh land mass right it's a tropical
archipelago you would expect high
biological diversity because tropical
habitats tend to have high biological
diversity but it doesn't because it's so
remote right it's remote and that means
things don't get to hawaii and so what's
there are things that were very good at
crossing extremely long inhospitable
distances
right so it's a interesting habit lots
of unique things there but it's not high
diversity
you can take almost any mainland
creature there that finds it
climatically hospitable and the thing
will take off because you've solved the
hard problem of getting to hawaii by
taking it there on an airplane and now
it's a better competitor than all the
things that were adapted for getting to
a place like hawaii and persisting there
so the point is
we've introduced creatures we've
introduced you know mongoose for example
you can't get rid of them right what
you've just done is solved an
evolutionary problem that evolution
couldn't solve and then you've let
evolution take it from there and this is
a recipe for disaster the idea that
you're going to create something in a
lab and think that you're its master
come on
this is natural selection it built you
right this is the most powerful process
for you know upending plans that could
conceivably exist and you're just
playing with fire and what's more you're
not playing with fire in the way that
people used to play with firework they
would blow themselves up you're talking
about the whole world somebody made an
error in fact in this case people were
wise enough to see it coming and they
tried to ban this research and anthony
fauci decided to override them
right
that error anthony fauci overriding a
gain of function
research ban very likely resulted
in a particular viral particle escaping
off a particular lab bench into a
particular human being and then covid19
right that is the the capacity of
selection to take a tiny error right
literally a microscopic error and turn
it into a global catastrophe that's the
power of the process you're [ __ ] with
and if you don't respect it
you know we're going to be facing this
again and again because our power is
only
growing with respect to starting these
things to setting them in motion
and you know oh it's such a terrible
terrible failure of wisdom
i completely agree so yeah rant on i
know i i'm i'm
the older i get the less i know you know
and and so i loved i loved the um
evolution and darwinism that i was
taught in grad school and
about five years out i realized it was
complete junk you know i've been i've
been trained that lamarck was wrong and
darwin won and this guy was an idiot and
this guy was super smart and then i came
across this study that i had to read and
check and recheck and check and it blew
my mind it was um they had been trying
to look at up regulation of nasal tissue
um the receptors and so what they were
doing was they took male mice and they
spritz cherry scent into the cage and
they shocked him at the same time
and as these stories often go one day
there was a sharp graduate student who
noted that they forgot to they they
forgot to shock them but they spritzed
the cherry sent
the mouse all acted with this ptsd right
because they'd been habituated to
associate the the cherry scent with a
painful shock
well what they found was that the pups
from the offspring of those of those
male mice when they bred them would
display that ptsd behavior upon exposure
to the cherry sent no shock
so that and then that persisted through
multiple generations so it means that
our dna has a way of taking
experiences
saying that sucked let me help pass that
on coding it up and giving it to our
offspring right
that's not what i learned in evolution
right that means our dna is in
communication with the world now we have
this epigenetic and there's offspring of
auschwitz survivors who have more
anxiety we've got the dutch studies of
the babies that were that were fasted
while they were in utero
gaining weight afterwards we understand
now that our dna is not this static it's
busy in a call and response dynamical
process with the world
the complexity of that is not something
i can even begin to think we have our
arms around
we don't and what's more
so i do think the epigenetic revolution
is uh
one of the um
the reasons for hope in what is
otherwise
a
desert of recent progress in
evolutionary thinking
but the problem is it was implied by
many things we knew very well back when
i was in college
right we didn't know what we were
dealing with in terms of the mechanisms
but the point is
development actually implies all of
these mechanisms the very fact that you
can take a genome and it can create
hundreds of different cell types that
are well organized into a coordinated
organism
and that the pattern involves those
cells
being able to count
you know their progress from the zygote
and being able to respond as we know
that they can to different environmental
cues during that process so for example
you know a tadpole that ends up in a
puddle that has other things other meat
to eat develops one kind of dentition a
tadpole of the same type
that is left in a puddle that only has
vegetable matter develops different
dentition this implies a system in which
the genes are able to read the
environment and alter their own
expression right it's all there and the
problem is if you took back in the 80s a
what do the data say
approach and the point is well the data
don't yet say
what the epigenetic landscape is capable
of but the point is
yes but it has to be
there's no way this could fail to exist
and so you could either anticipate it
and say i don't know what that layer
looks like but there's a missing layer
and you know people i agree with what
you said except for
darwin
did get it right
and what i mean by this is darwin was a
generalist he was in some cases a few
cases overly specific but in general he
did a good job of laying out the logic
by which selection would function
without being so specific that he is
upended by history and so in some sense
it's what happened later the discovery
of dna and its its
nature as the fundamental genetic uh
storehouse
caused a narrowing of focus where what
happened is
darwin said something very general he
didn't say there was going to be one
mechanism
right but then at the point that we had
this very compelling mechanism it was
like ah that's darwin's mechanism and no
one stopped to think maybe it's one of
darwin's mechanisms and so my sense is
more and better darwinism is the
solution to the flaws of modern
darwinism
i love it oh thanks ted yeah no i guess
it you know it had to have been the
overlay because i guess what i'm really
reacting to is the overlay of saying
well the way darwin's evolution must
work is there must be this random
mutation
it confers a set of of attributes and
some of those are selected for and some
are selected against but but those never
made sense to me because i'm like
so
duck
ducklings there was a random mutation
where a duckling would freeze when a
certain shape went overhead and so that
was the one that didn't get picked off
so it survived like it didn't make sense
i think now it makes more sense to me
that the duckling is like oh man that
sucked let me pass that on right that
there's some
there's some rat more rapid more elegant
way of of communicating uh but at any
rate i i got i came up through molecular
biology at a time when it was
here's dna it's in a string stop codon
start stop start codons you know and uh
it codes out and if you've got this
mutation you have sickle cell anemia
right it's like it was very
dry now i understand it's a little more
more i mean the problem is that we write
the the bio textbook in the same
voice that we write the chemistry
textbook and the fact is we're a lot
farther along in chemistry we know more
of what there is to know and we're
really at the very beginning with
biology and so what i tend to say is
the the story in the biology textbook
about random mutations being selected
most of them being bad or neutral the
occasional one being good that story
isn't false it's true but that's the
original thing that set the ball in
motion we're looking at selection 10.0
where selection has done amazing things
to enhance its own capacity
right and so if you use an understanding
of evolution 1.0 and you try to
understand things that are unfolding in
evolution 10.0 space
you're just not going to get anywhere
right this is a very powerful process
and i mean even the tools that we're
using to have this discussion
these are tools selection
built
to enhance the capacity of its own
products to do jobs that the genes
themselves couldn't do right
we you know people will swear to you as
they're training you to think about
evolution evolution cannot look forward
really
well can it build creatures that can
look forward because i think we are
those creatures and
if evolution can build creatures that
look forward on its behalf is it really
fair to teach people that evolution
can't look forward because the truth is
not exactly that it's more misleading
than it is helpful
so we're constantly stuck in that bind
and what you're saying which i of course
completely agree with
is that that stupid hubris that should
have made somebody look foolish in a lab
meeting actually resulted in us crashing
the
functional structures of civilization
over
what at best was you know an error a lab
error
right that that is an unacceptable cost
benefit ratio for such experiments right
we should not all be suffering from some
uh you know
naive person's
uh attempt to do something on their lab
bench that just so happened to you know
walk out of the lab on their shoe or in
their lung
yeah
yeah it and then it um
so
the thing i've been struggling with
covid wise um is
is the degree to which then that error
was seized upon
really quickly by some people who seemed
almost quite ready for it we know they
were right they were doing these event
201 trainings if people don't know what
that is they would bring together
a bunch of interested parties who would
talk about how would we manage a a viral
outbreak across the globe right and and
so who do they bring in that room well
you're not invited i'm not invited i
don't think any scientists are in there
it's like j and j executives some people
from the cia every major news media
outlet bill and melinda gates foundation
um you know etc and and and they bring
them in and when they ran those events
what was startling to me brett was
watching that they they never i don't i
i watched the whole thing and i didn't
see them ever go here's how we limit the
loss of human life they're like
you know there's this bad narrative that
might get out and people are going to be
spreading misinformation and they had
sub teams and here's how we would
control the narrative and it was really
just all about how do we control this
thing
but back to our point
when you unleash a virus on the world
like this it is fundamentally an
uncontrollable it's going to do things
it's going to get out and do what it's
going to do it's good virus is going to
virus right and
and it's done that it's made new
variants it's it's uh it taught us that
putting a leaky vaccine
into a pandemic was a really bad idea
like gear vandenberg said it would be um
and on and on and on and we got
thank goodness that omicron came along
we could have a different conversation
about that but what's astonishing to me
is how many people
were gleefully anticipating this exact
sort of an outbreak so that they could
do the kinds of things they wanted to do
like
ovid passports and
shutting down sectors of the economy
right
that it was in our interest to surrender
our rights that the key to accessing our
rights was surrendering them right these
kinds of upside-down
bits of logic and
um
you know i i fear that one of the facets
of the game that is about to unfold is
interrupting the natural process of
learning that people and societies go
through
what do you mean what i mean is the
lessons here are fairly obvious i mean
for one thing if this you know it let's
imagine that this happened at a much
smaller scale or that something
analogous happened at a much smaller
scale you know a town
right and people had been very very
wrong and they had been very very
convincing and
a disaster of one's size had been made
much worse through
their inaccuracy
right there would be a discussion and
the discussion would say well
i don't know how you got it so wrong and
frankly i don't know why you listen i
listen to you but i do know
that you're not the expert on this
anymore right your advice caused us to
harm ourselves you are now the last
person we will go to for advice on these
kinds of situations right and those
people that we went after
that we tried to silence because we
thought that what they were doing you
told us that what those people were
saying was dangerous to us and that we
needed to silence them and we needed to
punish them right
you were wrong and in fact it turned out
they were right so believe it or not
i'm going to them next i'd like to know
what they see doesn't make them right
but it does mean that they have a tool
kit that has proven out
we are going to be prevented from
learning that lesson
we are going to be prevented from
understanding you know effectively as
much as possible will be driven to a
muddle
that does not produce the proper
reaction to correct the process so
exactly the thing that we were talking
about earlier that makes a biologist
smarter
where you walk into a system you know
nothing about you take your best shot
you see what worked what didn't and your
model that you carry around in your mind
gets improved by
uh you know by just simply actually the
human desire to figure it out right the
human desire to figure it out says damn
i thought that prediction was going to
be right why wasn't it you know i want
to be right next time whatever it is
that process would upgrade our thinking
but that's bad business
this happened for a reason you and i
don't know what it is let's assume that
it started with a well-intentioned but
crazy research
uh project that got out of hand
collapsed uh many of the functional
structures of the world
and
that the right thing to do now is to
figure out holy crap what did we do
wrong what's what's wrong in our
granting process what's wrong in our
governmental agencies what's wrong in
the kinds of projects that that exists
what does dual use mean
should there be
this dual use argument right you can
study how to cure diseases with
dangerous viruses as long as they also
have some utility as weapons what
none of this makes any sense so
um
i don't know whether there's any
stopping
the uh
the process that is about to recapture
the narrative and steer it into some
um
ineffectual
state
but i do think that this is something
that we have to focus on because
everything is riding on this i mean you
and i both have children
right they're going to have to have a
planet that functions and the power to
cause catastrophes like this is going to
grow so our wisdom and how to prevent
them from happening needs to as well
even if you know this just freezes our
knowledge in place that's a disaster
so
i don't know we we've got to get better
at this and we've got to get good at
recognizing that there's a spectrum of
possibilities about what actually
happened here right the story that you
described there i think is probably
at least partially true where people
when they saw this thing emerge they had
plans already in place to allow them to
capitalize on it
right to use it for things they wanted
to do anyway right for making tyrannical
incursions into our rights right they
had that on their agenda and they needed
a way to do it and suddenly oh covet
that's it all right let's do that
so we need to
we need to recognize the possibilities
and
i think
a good healthy dose of agnosticism about
what has taken place is important
because it may be actually that there's
more to this than we know
i yeah the the idea that
you mentioned this about what what kind
of world are we leaving behind here for
the kids um
it's
so i'm of an age where i remember
what the world looked like when i was a
boy because i was out i was i was called
nature boy i was always outside
and i delighted in just catching things
um turtles snakes frogs fish uh insects
whatever um so i was out there and i
didn't realize to me i just took it for
granted like this is the world i live in
right i distinctly remember when we what
my family's from as a summer place
upstate new york on a finger lake and i
remember as a boy
literally being
wonderfully frightened i love this kind
of frightening when you would turn on
the porch light and if you came back
later the screen door would be covered
with this like terrifying array of
things right giant walking sticks huge
staghorn beetles big sphinx and luna
mods it was just you know things banging
in that you couldn't quite resolve
in uh last five years
nothing like you can leave the window
open all night with a light on inside
and if you get one lonely moth you know
you're lucky now
um so that level of of horrifying change
to me
tells me that that we don't just need to
sort of like point out that anthony
faucis is a bad guy that what we need is
is if we're gonna if evolution you know
if consciousness can come in and help
redirect itself a little bit we've got
some growing up to do as a species like
like
covet can be a wake-up call and i think
it has been for many people but i think
it has to wake us up to something even
bigger than a failure of the cdc to be
an effective institution um it has to
wake us up to something bigger than geez
can we get a couple of better candidates
for president next time it's it's it's
much bigger than that and so that's i
don't know how to get at that yet at
this point in time but but that's really
where i'm steering my efforts is using
covet as a means of reaching people who
are ready to wake up
and and use our brains towards abundance
and regeneration rather than just
extraction and depletion um
and and that's as close as i've gotten
to it i'm not remotely smart enough to
know how to begin
doing anything other than having the
conversation and hoping people are
attracted to that and and that's what i
see this year is about is
we have to have that conversation
because in my lifetime i've seen
this the oceans have become almost
sterile and i'm using that word very
carefully compared to what they were
yeah i've seen exactly the same thing
and this is you know you know it's funny
the folks on the center right who we end
up interacting with now
are correct about a good many things and
this is one of the things i think
they're way wrong about and i think we
have to have that conversation with our
natural partners on both
left and right so that they
so that we can upgrade our collective
model and let me just be candid about
your observation about the insects i've
made exactly the same observation and i
was a very
uh creature oriented kid too and so i
played a lot in nature as much as
possible and i caught creatures just
like you and i remember a world in which
a uh
drive a summer drive down the highway
resulted in
just an
awful
very difficult to clean up mess on the
windshield
right the number of insects that died on
the windshield of your car was a real
problem right they were sticky and there
were
products that were sold you know you
could read in a magazine products to get
the goo off your windows because it
wasn't an easy job but the point is the
world has changed
the oceans are
so much less diverse than they once or
or maybe diverse is the wrong word but
there's so much less in them right and
the number of insects is way down and
there are places you can go
where you used to hike and see you know
a diversity of birds you couldn't avoid
seeing it and now you see nothing and
here's the part i got wrong
i would have said as a as a 20 year old
that if the collapse of the insect
population was as severe as you and i
both know it is
that that would have had catastrophic
effects on agriculture for example
and i don't think it has i think
agriculture has
pivoted and it be it functions
differently than it once did it is a
much more robust
process
because it's high tech it's robust to
this particular insult it's feeble with
respect to many other things so for
example
the super crops right super corn
isn't super at all
right it's incredibly weak the point is
it grows
incredibly big if you dump fertilizer on
it but it's completely incapable of
growing you know with any sort of
natural competition in the absence of
those inputs so anyway we're living in
some system that didn't behave
according to the fears that i had
but nonetheless the collapse of the
insect population is every bit as severe
as we worried it would be and maybe more
severe so
i don't know we have to have the
conversation and we have to have the
conversation about what it implies right
and in some sense
the good news about covet 19
is that it showed
how vulnerable we are
and not just at the level of
our biology it showed how
vulnerable we are
to propaganda and to being induced to
viciousness toward each other and
demonizing those who are trying to tell
us things we need to know
right so this was a trial run and if we
learned the lesson of it we could come
out of it much stronger but then again
that's the reason that i'm afraid the
lesson is going to be buried
so i'm keen on this like um
how how we get out of this and it's a
multi-step process so
you you've you've bumped into one of the
aspects of this for me which is the mass
psychosis
story mass formation more technically
i like the word psychosis because
well it's sort of more evocative but
but the idea that that there were a
group of people who fell prey rather
easily to
a a set of narratives that were
not just provably false but demonstrably
ridiculously previously provably false
but i understand the process that we got
here and it's disappointing to me
because
um these events that we
go we're spending so much time
in this mass formation event and we're
not using that energy for other things
that i think really need and deserve our
like full full full full attention um
and there's so many i love how john
michael greer put it a long time ago he
said you know problems have solutions
that's fine we can all talk about
problems but predicaments
have outcomes and you got to manage
those right so
um so i see us facing a number of
predicaments and we have to decide as
adults how we want to begin managing
those
energy is a huge one when you look at
where we are in fossil fuel consumption
still plenty there it's not forever
when you really understand that what has
to happen at scale time cost
sociologically and culturally in order
to get there even if we have 50 years
you realize the best time to have
started this would have been back when
jimmy carter put the cardigan on and the
solar panels on the roof right that
would have been a great time and we
haven't and we've sort of dilly-dallied
along so so i'm i'm worried that what
i'm seeing now is that they
have a really powerful set of tools to
distract people and keep us
focused on things that are of no
importance and i hope i don't piss off
too many people saying that but we have
been focusing we've been navel gazing in
this country
and on things that are fundamentally not
even on the problem scale let alone the
predicament scale in this right
so
i know a lot of people take it super
important that you know are there 50
genders or 60 i mean it's just like in
the scheme of things once you understand
what we're up against with with the
species issues and with energy you might
say okay
we'll put that on the list but it's not
it's not on my it's not at the top of my
priority list yeah i agree
i'm worried about no idea
you have to have traveled somewhere
that's really dysfunctional to
understand how much trepidation you
should have about disrupting a system
that works even if it has terrible flaws
that you dislike right
there should be trepidation about
upending a civilization that functions
and look
i'm a died in the wool
liberal i grew up in a liberal household
i'm as troubled by the failure of our
system
uh to be
fair and decent as anyone but
the solution is to improve it the
solution is not to wreck it because we
invite
absolute catastrophe
by wrecking it and by concentrating on
things that shouldn't be at the top of
the priority list that is exactly what
we will do um so
i i wholeheartedly agree that that's a
tremendous hazard i will point out for
my listeners
that
um
mass formation psychosis suddenly became
a feature of people's thinking at the
point that robert malone talked about it
with joe rogan
you had had matthias desmond on your
program
because you saw how important this was
that was before
robert malone went on on rogan and
talked about it and it had been
a concept that was being circulated
amongst people who were thinking clearly
about this
before that so you saw that this
bubbled into the conversation of people
who were making sense you recognized how
important it was
you amplified it to people who follow
you
and then i don't know a month later
it became something that dawned on
people was important and what i would
point out is that this is a general
pattern there is a conversation
of people
who
stared down the stigmas that were thrown
at us
it's a much better smarter conversation
than what the public is being exposed to
right it's a conversation that sees
things coming right if you were paying
attention to
garet vandenbush then you know
that variance was an issue you were
thinking already about the insanity
of an absurdly narrowly targeted vaccine
that couldn't help but drive
uh
the evolution of this virus to some new
place
you knew that it was nonsense that this
was going to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated that the variants were
going to be the result of the large
population of unvaccinated people you
knew all that way ahead of time and if
you're standing where they expect you to
stand you hear about these things late
you hear about them right along with the
phony debunk [ __ ] and you don't know
what to think and so part of the
question for people
who are trying to figure out how they
can protect themselves from this whether
or not civilization learns the lesson
how they can get smarter so that they
don't end up victims of this again part
of the question is how are you going to
figure out
what conversation to tune into so that
you'll see all of this stuff coming and
the the unpleasant answer to that is
the
stigmas the
vilification that was used to prevent
people from figuring out who to listen
to the point is when those of us who did
stand up were vilified publicly
that was to persuade other people
not to come near us it's too expensive
you don't want to do it
and
you know i can't say it isn't expensive
but i can say if you wanted to know what
was coming that was the way to do it was
to ignore those stigmas and listen to
people who were trying to warn you
that it's uh
that's where all the all the actual
information was at the edges it wasn't
coming from the center it was all at the
edges it's kind of like jordan hall
talks about like you know that
the the the that's the great part of the
internet so so i found
all the value i had was from listening
to people like robert malone and peter
mccullough and and yourself and and um
pier corey and all the flcc doctors paul
merrick and on and on and on these were
people who who they didn't always get it
right but i could tell that they were
intensively caring about trying to get
it right um
and so it was amazing that way but i'm
wondering um
like what was the cost to you uh
because you you in many ways took way
more slings and arrows than i did um you
know you paid some prices i don't know
whether i should talk about this
publicly or not but i'm going to do it
um
this has been a process
of
the creation of anti-fragility
and the stuff that was pointed at
heather and me was
it was incredibly
difficult i mean the just the simple
volume of it at its worst was
there was no way to grapple with it
right you just knew that there were
vile slanders being delivered that you'd
never even know were said because you
just couldn't even look at it all even
if that was your instinct so um it was
very unpleasant
it was also not our first rodeo
and so
there's a way in which yeah this one was
the worst one i've ever seen by far
but there was also
an awareness that there's a process to
it and that one gets through that and
the point is live to fight another day
and this process actually makes you
stronger in the end
so there were moments at which i doubted
that and i mean i still do i still
wonder if
the um
[Music]
the vindication of all of the points
that have been correct is going to be
buried
specifically for the purpose of
preventing uh
me and and others like you from speaking
up again in the face of the next one
right so i know that the thing is still
very interested
in capitalizing uh on the progress that
it made psychologically
i also know from talking to people that
people have a
very wrong impression
of where we currently are in other words
they directed at this incredible
onslaught at us and it was
uh
i don't even have the words for what it
was like it was just like you know it
was a fire hose of awful
but
in the end
we are now in the position of watching
this large this ever growing population
of people
recognize
who was trying
to warn them
and who was actively steering them into
danger
and that is incredibly gratifying so
um it was bad but every time they do
this and they leave us standing we get
stronger that's the thing
so
so you had some dark days but you but
you'd been there before so you kind of
knew what was coming or did you ever
lose hope like that oh my god yeah i
mean i still i still worry about that um
but
again
a i think that we are at a point where
the scale of the disasters is
is now so great that in effect they have
tied our hands right we might as well
fight
right because the solution of not
fighting that's going to be a short ride
so
we have to fight that would have been my
inclination and i know your inclination
also
and yeah they created some dark days but
in the end i'm not at all convinced they
didn't
uh their plan didn't backfire
and that they didn't you know
let's put it this way i told
people who were close to me back when
the lab leak story broke right and of
course nobody has formally acknowledged
that this is what happened but we all
know that the evidence has gotten
stronger and stronger
i told them look
that was a surprise win i didn't think
we were going to win that one i knew we
had to fight it but i didn't think we
were going to win
having won it there are now two others
right there's the question of early
treatment
and there's the question of vaccine
safety and efficacy
if the public wakes up on all three of
those fronts
suddenly we now know something
we know
that the following systems
have completely failed to protect us and
in fact have steered us into greater
danger
the academy
the press
big tech
the public health apparatus and all of
the governmental structures it is
plugged into
that is an amazing across-the-board
failure
and
no one who is paying attention could
possibly look at a failure of all of
those things
and come away with the impression that
anything small could possibly put us
back on track so
the reason
that we put ourselves in danger
in this case
was that
there's a process i described which is
that certain stories diagnosed the
system
right the evergreen story diagnosed the
press
right
part of the press couldn't report it
because it went in the wrong direction
for their audience and another part of
the press could report it and so it
revealed this process of like everybody
can report the stories about the other
side and they don't report the stories
about their own side so the new york
times completely [ __ ] it up well they
have [ __ ] it up there were people on
the editorial page but never mind the
point is
and across the board failure as we have
seen with covid is a dire emergency
having nothing to do with covid
pandemics drugs vaccines anything it is
a dire
dire failure of the systems on which we
are depending
and my hope is
that this failure having been
revealed at great cost to many of us
now allows us to have the conversation
we need to have which is the same one
that you raised about the insects and
their
collapse
right we are
screwing up the things on which we
depend and that is
a suicidal thing to do
so
i don't know uh
i'm hopeful and that you know before we
close this out we should talk about this
march that is upcoming tomorrow which
you and i both have a relationship with
but neither of us will be at
um but i think we are at that moment
where the system has revealed itself and
i don't know that in our lifetimes we
will get a better opportunity to have
the conversation we need to have about
civilizational collapse which is looming
because these systems have stopped doing
what they're supposed to do
that's it right there and and so that's
my actually my greatest fear is i'm
going to wake up one day and
biden and macron and all the other
leaders and are going to just go oh yeah
hey this is just like the seasonal flu
let's endemic we're done let's move on
um because
why is that a fear because it means that
that we won't we won't have that
accounting of it that we need that
they'll just try and like slide past
those failures i think those failures
need to be brought forward not not not
to rub their noses in these particular
failures but because of what you just
said that
they're indicative of a larger systemic
sort of an issue that's been going on
and i don't know really how big or how
deep it is is it just
the peter principle played out over too
many generations you know where the
inept rise well past their abilities or
or is this just you know strauss and
half turning guess what late stage
empire things get over complicated
joseph tainter's style and
you know this is just how it is you know
you got to go through the decay function
um at the end of these things
but my view brett is that we don't have
so
there were plenty of times for empires
to sort of wax and wane in times past
this time is different and i know those
are dangerous words to say and why is it
different it's because we're just
in the resource story we are just not we
don't have a lot of fat left on this
particular animal um to live off of and
make mistakes so i i just feel like the
mistakes we make today are more profound
than the ones people made in times past
because we were younger then right it's
like you know
you drive to the hole too hard in
basketball as an 18 year old and you
know break something
you recover you know you slip on the ice
as an 80 year old and it's just a
different story right so
at any rate that that's that's my
concern is i want to make sure we're
having those proper conversations
because i actually think this is one of
the most pivotal moments in human
history
that it's extraordinary time to be alive
and the way we begin to address this is
we have to have really open honest
conversations where literally you know
no ox is too sacred to gore everything
on the table we need all hands on deck
on this thing i i i believe in actual
diversity like real diversity but that
diversity is in here
right
um and so that's what i'm
really kind of hopeful for is that is
that you know we get to join forces we
find these other people to me that's
what this next part is about is
gathering us
and maybe the march is a great segue
into that people are going to get around
a set of purposes
nominally you know defeat the mandates
but but it has to be bigger than that i
see the march needs to be the start of
something not the not the cherry on top
of it yeah uh let's get to the marks in
a second and let's just sort of collect
our gains on what you and i have both
just said i think painting with a broad
brush what we have said is
the level of dysfunction in the system
is
will be fatal
for humanity
in short order
covid reveals those failures and it
reveals them in a case that is obviously
survivable but the point is it says none
of the things somebody has unhooked all
of the things that are supposed to allow
you to steer the ship back on course and
away from the iceberg right and that
doesn't mean that there's an iceberg but
there will be sooner or later
so that is an emergency of the highest
order it's not a covet emergency covid
reveals the emergency right
the second thing to say is that kovid
because of the across-the-board failure
of everything
reveals the problem
and there's no reason to think we are
going to get a better chance in our
lifetimes to actually discuss it right
the curtain is never going to be pulled
this far back again right or if it is it
may be too late right the next emergency
may not be such a survivable one so
we have to talk we have to figure out
what's gone wrong and we have to fix it
because
our job is to leave the planet
intact for future generations they have
to have a decent planet to live on and
this is going to screw it up permanently
right so we have to talk about it and
we're never going to get a better better
shot and that tells us where we are and
what has to happen next right and yes
the gathering of people who get some
fraction of that story or see it from
some perspective that they can translate
it between what we've just said and what
they're saying
those are the people that need to be
talked to and
and now is certainly the time
now let's talk about the mark right you
and i were both involved in
uh planning the march and discussing
what its focus should be
um i know that i have hopes for what
will happen
i have concerns
about what will happen and
my concerns motivated me
to decide not to go to the march because
my thought was
the march contains so many of the voices
who have been important in revealing the
covet 19
catastrophe
that
it is an obvious vulnerability and that
you know while i don't really expect
um
somebody to commit violence against
speakers i do worry that an all-out
effort will be made to portray the march
as something other than it is
and i felt it was important to stay away
so that if that happens there is
somebody who is involved in the planning
who can say you know what
i was there i know what the intended
message was i know what the view was on
violence and frankly ideology of all
kinds
and let me tell you what that looked
like on the inside so basically i was
hoping to function
as a dead man switch
now i know that
you were thinking about the same thing
and then i know that you ended up with
covid which effectively
made meant that there wasn't even a
decision that needed to be made in your
case
but what do you see
what i saw was um
ivermectin go from from from a
toxicology standpoint it's literally the
safest compound i've ever looked at like
it's literally that safe it's it's
curved between effective dose and lethal
doses so wide
you know you'd have to be a real [ __ ]
to to somehow you know jump over that in
fact when we saw that there was this
incredible uh study by jacques cote you
looked at 500 different things at
studies and
zero deaths had ever been recorded that
they could directly ascribe to it so
it's that safe
and then we watched the farm again the
campaign come out where i woke up one
day and all of a sudden it was horse
dewormer everywhere because somebody had
decided that's what needed to happen now
obviously that wasn't organic right it
had a lot of useful willing idiots who
were ready to parrot that because it was
a team sport or something but but
somebody you we know some people sat in
a room
said look we can't get this on safety
what do we do with this and they had
enough power to blanket the airwaves
have major articles all appear in all
the major newspapers have it show up on
all the major you know cnn msnbc have it
even have the fda itself tweet out a
little y'all stop taking horse dewormer
right
so that's power and so we know that
there's like lots and lots of money
interested in making sure that this
march is not successful or is seen a
certain way
and we've seen their early sort of
entrees there was a
an article which i'm air quoting because
it's it was really an opinion piece in
the washington post that said
anti-vaxxers gathering into revel
something they're right in the games of
their once fringe movement or some
garbage like that
something like that yes
so yeah it's it's you know it's an etvx
mardi gras it's gonna be amazing we're
throwing beads you know but it's just
seeing so that i think that old trope of
calling everybody you disagree with
either hitler or an anti-vaxxer is
wearing thin that's that's not like a
really compelling argument i don't know
if you're still buying it but you can
see you fail
yes exactly so so but but the point is
that there are i guarantee you there are
people who are very smart
sitting in a room thinking how do we
make this how do we how do we shape this
how do we how do we use this to our
advantage how do we
make it not be what it needs to be or
how do we recast this and so we know
there's going to be an effort to
january 6th it which is which is a
shorthand for saying cast it in a whole
new light other than it actually
occurred under so that we can minimize
it or worse right so so i do i have my
concerns it's not a concern
i'm positive
that there are people thinking how to
um harm that particular thing because it
upsets their plans it upsets their their
income statements it upsets their
political ambitions
whatever the story is um so i know i
know there's going to be a yes they're
going to be people who are going to be
trying to
disrupt it
yep there's too much at stake
there's problems at stake
there's the potential for
uh criminal trials if if you if you
if you hold what i hold to be true about
the suppression of early treatments i
see that as a um as beyond civil uh
that's a criminal right so there's a
possibility
of trials there's the possibility of
congressional hearings with musical
interludes from hamilton i mean
you know that sounds like a joke but
we've seen this we know
we know how the people in power are
playing a narrative game and that they
are basically uh
i'm tempted to say shameless monsters
but i will stop it obviously shameless
right their willingness to portray
uh something of as something else is
without limit
and you know the thing that i
found myself you know the people i met
organizing the thing
i think are very good patriotic decent
people right and i think this was you
know they were called to do something
that was not in their skill set because
they were just simply moved by human
suffering and the need to to do
something and this seemed like the
obvious thing to do it was however a
little bit hard to convey
look the game theory here
is not favorable
we've got you know and i keep saying
hundreds of billions of dollars at stake
in
covid and the public health response
and people who
have been slightly deeper into the
finances keep telling me no it's a
trillion at least
right but even if it's hundreds of
billions of dollars at stake
that means
that it makes sense to spend many
millions it would make sense to spend
billions to derail an effort that is
potentially going to interrupt their
ability to sell their garbage narrative
and impose their
mandates so you can be certain that
there is it's not a small effort that is
being pointed at figuring out how to
derail
uh the march and what it stands for so i
i do have concerns and my senses
maybe
the collapse of the narrative
and our absence from that stage and
therefore our ability to speak to what
actually took place inside of the
planning maybe that is sufficient to
drive them off so that the only thing
they do
is
say nasty things that nobody's really
paying attention to anymore in all of
the outlets that they've captured right
that's inevitable and as you point out
has already begun
um if if that is
the limit of what they do i think that's
a tremendous success so let's let's hope
that that's what unfolds tomorrow
well and and yes
since this is going out before the march
i can tell you flat out obviously every
conversation we've ever had this is a
peaceful gathering these are people
wanting to have their voices be heard
these are people who want to let other
people see that other people care they
want to just exercise their basic rights
to gather um which is a very basic right
in this country still and that the
organizers have put out things that that
have
i think are right which is to say hey
if you see somebody trying to you know
stir up some trouble stop them you know
point them out to the authorities right
away stay in our you know within the
lanes that we've
agreed to all of that stuff because
nobody's here to cause trouble right
if trouble is being caused at any point
that's because somebody showed up
wanting to cause that trouble and those
could be
antifa guys who do just like to cause
trouble because that's what they're up
to or it could be a jean's provocateurs
or or it could be you know paid
paid actors from
you know certain companies i don't know
but i'm i bret i'll tell you my i know a
lot of people going to this um and uh
from from my my tribe and my side and as
well all the other people who are going
to be on stage there i don't know
anybody who's showing up with anything
other than peaceful intent at this point
so i just want to get that narrative out
there right now because
that the intent is uh
a
an exercise of speech
um
fully peaceful and
there's nothing there's nothing past
that but you know
the
reality is we have no idea how many
people are showing up right we know
what it looked like to the website and
the number of people who signed up
suggests an absolutely gigantic crowd
because most people don't sign up for a
free event that you could just go to
right so
the sky is the limit with respect to how
many americans might show up to this
thing on the other hand we don't know
that somebody hasn't decided to mislead
the organizers by
you know using bots to sign up with you
know uh burner email addresses and
maybe you know it's gonna be
i don't know ten thousand but uh but
nonetheless we do know the people who
are going i know i will just tell you
it was not even discussed inside of
those meetings who had been vaccinated
and who wasn't it was a mixture of
people right
some of the people organizing are
vaccinated some of them are not
that wasn't the point the point was
these mandates are un-american draconian
and dangerous and they are being
motivated by something that has nothing
to do with protecting the public
and they have to be opposed and so it
was time that americans join this global
resistance to
this fervor for mandates which is
obviously about something else even if
we can't say exactly what that something
is
yeah no it had nothing it was i th there
was not a single conversation on any of
the planning meetings i was on that
talked about vaccination status
nope
i know there are people on there who are
very pro-vaccine who are anti-mandate
and there are people on there who have
not been vaccinated but aren't anti-vaxx
because they're just not these vaccines
um right and and and i i put myself in
that in that camp it's just
uh yeah no it's not about that but we're
you know they're going to try and
characterize it as anti-vaxx because
because that
that's a
that's a that's a that's a dog whistle
for for certain people in this story
right as soon as you call this like
calling somebody a conspiracy theorist
it's just that
you just get to paint them with that
brush and
well it's really oh you're one of those
a
you know
scent that is applied to you to keep
others away right they're not going to
convince you or me
right or anybody who knows as well i
mean you know
am i an anti-vaxxer
i don't like these vaccines i don't
think they're wise they're too narrowly
focused there are too many design
failures built into them they're too
novel we know too little we know that
the trials that were done to establish
their safety were not high quality they
weren't large enough they didn't go on
long enough there are problems here that
a reasonable person can look at does
that make me anti-vaccine well let me
tell you something
i have given i don't know how many
lectures to my students about the glory
of the mechanism by which vaccines work
i think it's one of the most beautiful
stories i know i'm extremely pro-vaccine
in a general sense i will tell you that
watching pharma do this has made me
concerned about adjuvants in a way that
i wasn't before right i worry that
there's something about the way we
generate vaccines now that we and the
public need to know more about because
it's having effects on our immune system
that are more general than this basic
vaccine mechanism which i find so
beautiful but there's no way i mean you
know this this
michael gunner this australian guy
who every so often says the quiet part
out loud and we get to hear
what the plan really is you know who i'm
talking about i think he's from northern
australia and he every so often he says
something colorful about
you know
your personal vaccination status is
irrelevant if you are anti-mandates you
are anti-vaxx you know that guy right
yeah so anyway
is that they're gonna use that stigma
against anybody who has any reservation
about any vaccine or any measure that
might be used to
to get people to take it
and the point is anybody
with any level of intelligence
whatsoever knows that that is not a
definition that one could reasonably
apply if anti-vaxxer is a thing
then surely somebody who is pro-vaccine
and anti-mandate doesn't warrant it
somebody who is pro-vaccine in principle
but not pro-every single vaccine doesn't
warrant it right it's obviously a trick
it's a magic trick and frankly it's not
a very good one right it's not
compelling you have to want them to fool
you if you're buying that stuff and
if that's you you know
you have to look yourself in the in the
mirror
yeah
it and the whole the whole again the
whole
mass formation idea is to get you
focused down on stuff right it's like
hypnosis the idea is to get you so that
you're just focusing on this dot at the
tip of your nose and you can't even
resolve it's a dot i mean it's that it's
that hyper focus
and so we've been hyper focused for a
long time on kova deaths right
then you scratch at that a little bit
and you find out what was out of death
with or of and and next thing you know
we're battling over him on the
anti-vaxxer vaccines again it's too
narrow the point is that if we'd had a a
complete and authentic public health
response we would have said hey
how we doing in terms of all-cause
mortality you know a lot of reasons
people check off this mortal coil how we
doing and the answer is we're sucking at
it right 2000 was bad but 2001 was even
worse so by that objective measure we
can say whatever it is in total we're
doing worse and that's the conversation
we should be having so i worry every
time it gets pulled back down to
you know is it about these vaccines you
know because that's that's not they are
a component of what should be a very
rich tapestry of of things that we would
have in our tool kit at at the public
health level but it's always about that
and that's it and uh and you know we
don't even have brett at this point i
can't even point you to a single study
that says let's compare
unvaccinated people to vaccinated people
but these people got early treatment too
i don't know what that data looks like i
have strong suspicions i can infer it
from studies that don't you know that
sort of triangulate on it but we don't
have the actual data
how is that possible to not have data i
mean we've seen this this general
pattern which is
um i mean i hate to say it but you can
predict what the public health response
to something will be if it's actually
promising they don't like it right and
that should not be a pattern that is not
a pattern that suggests error that is a
pattern that suggests some other plan
and
it's uh it's appalling and i will just
say you know if you want to peek into
the resistance movement you know there
was this very good piece i would guess
that you saw it john campbell put out a
couple days ago on his channel about the
actual number of people in britain he's
british the actual number of people who
died of covid
right
and it was shocking right but here's my
point
john campbell is
absolutely welcome and on the radar of
people like you and me
he's pro-vaccine
he has been
very good at analyzing the data around
early treatment and ivermectin and he's
been courageous about talking about it
that's what the resistance movement
sounds like inside it's people who don't
have the same perspective on what makes
sense and what doesn't make sense but we
are coming to
agreement on what the tools of
measurement are that actually work
right
in the resistance movement everybody
knows that all cause mortality is an
important thing that is rarely conveyed
we know that we want autopsies done
because autopsies tell you something we
can't find out otherwise and we know
that the level of autopsies has been
artificially reduced and that suggests
that there is an obvious desire not to
know what kind of harm is being done
so
it is a big tent
right you're going to see that big tent
on the stage tomorrow at this march
because
you have people who have arrived from
you know as we began this discussion
they've arrived from
dozens of different paths to an
agreement that something has captured
our focus as you're pointing out and it
has mesmerized us into behaving in a way
that is actually harming us and
you know waking up from that
it's not going to be fun for a lot of
people but let me tell you the longer
you wait the less fun it's going to be
yeah that's
that's the main point here is look we
got to put a stop to this now and and
the way mass psychosis or formations are
stopped is with brave people standing up
saying
no let's stop we just let's stop
and so
uh
speaking of which we mentioned that you
know
every single time if there was something
favorable they
didn't like it um that data that john
campbell was talking about where they
showed that there was 17 300 people in
the whole covet experience all two years
had died of covin specifically who
weren't otherwise you know burdened with
a comorbidity
that came out because of a freedom of
information act request that data had to
be pried out and that should have been
put out there and broadcast by that same
organization if they were doing the
right thing right but instead you have
to pry it out and every time somebody
says hey chris what do you think of the
cdc report i'm like
uh i'm going to dig into it it's just
going to be crap you know um because i
know that they're going to use
redefinition statistical sleight of hand
they're going to ignore stuff the bad
study design it's just it's just been a
it's just been a horror show i mean this
whole thing on
natural immunity right
the cdc as recently as just a week ago
when they finally admitted oh hey
natural immunity looks kind of cool they
were using this really ridiculously
underpowered kentucky sort of database
sort of sleuthing thing where they only
had 290 examples to look at and then
they held that out it's like oh yeah
vaccines are better when we had this
extraordinary million-plus case count
case-matched cohort study out of israel
that said the opposite yeah
the cdc should have been there saying oh
here's why we don't like that study and
here's why we love they didn't they just
put this crappy study out and everybody
sent it to me like what do you think of
this i'm like uh
just
yeah
nothing wakes them and that tells you
that what they are is somehow a
a pr outfit right it's all broadcasting
things and you know one thing that has
been just
uh shockingly obvious to those of us who
have dug into it
is the level at which what people are
claiming as evidence pointing to the
public health narrative and its
prescription
is based on accounting fraud
right and you know you could look at one
instance of it and you could say well
maybe that's an error right maybe they
got the categories wrong
as an error but the number of places
where they have created a definition for
a category and they have shunted people
into it in order to amplify certain very
predictable messages right
what's the message the message is that
covet is very dangerous and it's killing
lots of people what's the message it's
that the vaccines are reducing harm to
people right what's the message is that
those without the vaccine are clogging
hospitals it's like they will just take
anything that points in that direction
and they will reorganize definitions
however they have to do it to to make
that appear to be the case and
any analysis that just simply doesn't
start with a
um a presupposition about
what landscape we're in
sees that that's nonsense and so you
start to tune it out right what do you
think of this latest ctc report why are
you asking me that has the cdc got
anything right here i'm not aware of it
right they've been wrong across the
board so
at some point you tune that out and you
go looking for something that isn't
consistently wrong
right something that is open to various
possibilities and you'll find that
that's a very vibrant discussion it just
you know to your earlier point
the interesting stuff is on the fringe
why because it was driven there
right the natural people who would be at
the head of the conversation of
figuring out what's going on in covet
and what we do about it those people
have been driven to the edge they've
either been silenced they've been
threatened and they've chosen to
self-censor or if they haven't been
willing to self-censor they've been
driven to the edge and so you know what
that's where you'll find them
absolutely yeah i was um very early on i
really cottoned on to the whole flccc
guys and i was helping them set up early
webinars and then i've been on the board
for a while and
and i
it's gotten a lot better since but i
remember the dark old days maybe i don't
know six eight months ago their facebook
page would get taken down they were
getting youtube strikes left and right
and having you know channels pulled down
and they were saying nothing other than
they were highly qualified medical
doctors discussing data that was it they
weren't out there railing against you
know what they thought you know pfizer
was full of crooks or anything like that
there was no nothing that would rise to
libel they were very careful and and
watching
that level of friction and hostility
that came at them was astonishing
never i'd never seen anything like that
before maybe you had in your battles wow
that was astonishing you know it's
astonishing in a way i'd never seen it
with doctors and there was something
just
impossible
uh
to stomach about watching these
obviously highly dedicated people who
actually save lives for a living they do
it
day in and day out
being treated as if they were
up to something right i mean it just
it couldn't possibly be more the inverse
of what was happening you had doctors
trying to be doctors trying to sort out
a live situation that we've all been
told is of utmost importance
and being demonized for the effort
because their conclusion didn't match
the public health authority which was
obviously wrong um and then to watch the
tech sector
leap to attention and start treating
them as if these were somehow you know
dangerous monsters it was just such a
preposterous
show a force on the part of whatever the
thing is that is arranging
the narrative
that you know
either you got it when you saw that or
you didn't and
um
yeah i'm glad those dark days are
are over but
um new dark days are coming
yep
yeah i i agree so
it's
we got a little dawn coming i mean i do
feel that the censorship has lightened
up a bit now for the march tomorrow i'll
tell you
um
there's going to be
there's this march and then and then
there's a bunch of people speaking so
they've invested in jumbotrons and the
stage and sound and all that stuff and
uh
uh unfortunately i won't be earlier to
speak that would have been fun uh
history moment but um there's a bunch of
bunch of the doctors i think are very
familiar names and then there's going to
be vaccine-injured people there talking
who finally get maybe a national
platform voice i can't even imagine how
awful it must be to be like the the
mother of of maddie gary stephanie gary
and know that you were doing the right
thing and then as soon as things went a
little wrong like the system just
basically said we think your daughter's
just nuts
and
no no support no
it's just awful um
but to hear from there'll be union
people there firemen um
uh just it's this is this is where i
think we get to see brett
just how broad this really is because
this isn't a bunch of anti-vaxxers this
is americans
who have some questions who feel like
they weren't allowed to ask those
questions and that felt wrong
and they they don't want to put up with
that anymore so that's what i'm excited
to see is
um
you know that this is the beginning of
something i hope which is us finding our
voice again
and yeah i don't know if i could pick up
on uh a theme
there's something about watching the
gaslighting of the injured
right if this was an honest effort to
control the pandemic and people had been
injured because we had a vaccine that
worked it had a unfortunately high price
a certain number of people
you know rolled the dice and it came up
bad for them we would take care of those
people right
and the point is
you did this so that we could be safe
and we could go back to life and the
point is these would be heroes we would
not be gaslighting them we would be
accepting that they were harmed they
would be getting free care for the rest
of their lives for
the cost that they paid on the rest of
our behalf and to watch them gaslit
tells you what kind of monsters we're
dealing with
the other thing that does that
for me at least
is the
withdrawal of
treatments that work early
right the idea that you're going to
simultaneously tell us we have this very
dangerous disease as you withdraw
therapies in which there is no profit
but that work
that is a level of indifference to human
suffering that is almost impossible to
imagine so those two facts
if i need to think about well what's
really going on here
i can check in with them and i can say
well at the very least whether this is
people making a decision in a conference
room or it's an emergent process it's a
monster right it is willing to actually
literally harm people
with a vaccine and then gaslight them
over whether or not they were harmed it
is willing to prevent people from having
medications that might protect them
might save their lives and
no process that is capable of those two
things
can can be defended it's not it's not an
accident and uh there is no decency to
it
at long last sir
have you exactly
uh
well is it reformable then because this
is this is a a topic like you know where
do we go and so
you know um you're going to be speaking
at an event i have coming up at the end
of this month um which is really about
asking that question what do we what do
we do like how do we organize ourselves
what should we do personally
individually
given all of this
i got to be honest i don't think it's
reformable i i don't when when something
is that far gone that it's lost that d
all shreds of detectable decency and
it's just about the money and the power
and you know damn the consequences of
the human suffering
i don't i don't think you can vote that
into a better position um yeah it's just
maybe that's defeatist in me but it's
kind of like you know if you if you
merge two companies and one's got a
toxic culture you just have to fire that
culture well and i've got bad news how
you start um
i'm certain that you are right it is
beyond reform
i am also certain that it must be
reformed
that that's actually the only thing we
can do
right you cannot
rebuild the system you're going to have
to take the edifice
and you're going to have to figure out
how to make it function in spite of the
fact that it is completely riddled with
corruption of various kinds
and you know in the end of what you said
there maybe you're hinting at the
process but the point is look
and heather and i talked about this on
our stream
yesterday in which we explored sort of
how we're feeling about
uh the various positions that people
took and what they're now doing as the
narrative comes apart
but i don't
i don't need to see fauci punished
i think he has
visited
one of the most
colossal catastrophes on planet earth
that we have ever seen and so it's not
that i couldn't justify the idea that he
needs to be punished but i don't i don't
need him punished what i do need
is for him never to be anywhere near
control over anything important ever
again right he has demonstrated from
lab leak through the vaccine catastrophe
he has demonstrated that whatever
happens when you give him power is bad
for people
okay he shouldn't be in power and we can
say that about many other people whose
names we don't necessarily know right
who have been
integral to the response here which has
been so disastrous
now we also have learned the names of
many people
who have integrity and who are willing
to stand up to garbage narratives and
tell us what we need to know rather than
what we want to hear
and so
there is an obvious solution and my
sense is you're going to watch
everything thrown at the question of how
to avoid it
right
everything will be thrown at the
uh the process of derailing an attempt
to simply take people who make sense and
put them in the positions where they can
do good
right that will be avoided at all costs
is uh is this uh a twisting of the
apocryphal churchill quote which is we
can count on them to do the right thing
after they've exhausted the other
opportunity the technology has moved on
since the moment that he said that and
so now we can count on a
smoldering fireball to persist after
they've exhausted every possibility
other than
the right one and so you know in some
sense it falls to people like us to
point out that the process is coming to
point out that it's happening and to
hopefully
um
wake people to it fast enough that
actually we do reform the system right
because it's not like
it's not like you couldn't take
reasonable people and put them in
positions of authority
and then here's here's the part here's
the good part i've given you the very
very dark part right the system is
beyond reform and yet that's our only
option all right
here's the bright side
i know from long experience that there
are three kinds of people in all of
these systems okay there are people who
will pursue their own interests no
matter who is harmed right they're not
very common but they exist
there are people who will do the right
thing no matter how costly it is to them
also not very common
and then there is a vast middle ground
of people who will do
what
they have to do
but they might prefer to do the right
thing right we can't spot them because
at the moment they are doing the wrong
thing why because they don't have a
better choice
and so my hope is
that if we actually do
manage to put decent people
with the proper
the proper expertise in the roles at the
heads of these organizations
then the populations of these
organizations yeah they have some bad
apples in them for sure but what they
also have is a lot of decent people who
haven't been given a decent choice and
that that actually
does
maybe suggest that reform could work
this is
in part why i'm i'm talking with you
today um is because one of the things
i've noticed is that uh
this fear that they've they have been
putting out has been very contagious
but i've watched the opposite i've
watched courage be just as contagious
and so it's really important that the
people
who have that capability to be
courageous do so so i'm really a
fortunate person because of how the
decisions i've made because of the the
position i put myself in i you know i
wasn't
i'm not going to stand here and tell you
i'm a super courageous guy because if i
was working at a job that i had three
kids at a certain position and you know
i had the golden handcuffs and you know
or whatever there's a lot of
circumstances
i'm not going to be a brave guy i just
know it um
and i was just found myself in a
position during this whole period of
time where i could take some risks sure
i could have lost my whole business but
you know i could figure something else
out
but um but i was able to really go
forward and just and just say what i
thought was true right and i saw the
effect that had and i watched incre but
watching somebody like pierre cory who's
just
dripping with integrity right watching
what happened when he ripped his mask
off in that senate testimony and i could
just feel the galvanizing effect of that
i was just like wow that is really
impressive and boy they're going to come
after this guy and they did right
um
that was my first youtube strike was
just replaying that video and remarking
as to how great i thought that was i got
bing got nuked on that one right
but i i just for everybody who's
listening to this right now like this is
the time for us to stand up and stand
together and just stand as courageously
as we can because i got
brett this is like this is the biggest
moment in history i'm aware of so many
things are going to be decided in the
next few years that we either go this
way or that way
and one of these ways is kind of dark
and the other way
might be might be difficult but it's a
lot less dark um
i think both both paths are kind of kind
of tricky but i got to be honest i i
think that what's been revealed here
says that if we allow these people who
want to go that way to win
i will regret that every but we'll all
regret that yeah um i said a couple
things i remember at the beginning of
the pandemic as
we were sort of all grappling with what
it was and what it meant you know
i was asked
well when will we go back to normal and
i heard myself say i knew i knew i
believed it as soon as i heard myself
say it
we're never going back to normal yeah
and um i also remember saying actually
this is the biggest thing that's ever
happened on planet earth
and i still believe this right now you
have
things that are
bigger in terms of megatonnage right you
have the use of nuclear weapons you have
world wars you have things like that but
this is a process this is a truly global
process that has unfolded here and the
irony that it begins with
something that is literally
microscopic
is
a big one the point is you're looking at
something that can amplify a microscopic
error into a global catastrophe that
tells you where we are and how much
danger there is and so your point about
if we go that way we will all regret it
inevitably that is exactly what will
happen we are looking at an amplifier
that can take a microscopic error and
turn it into a global catastrophe if you
don't get if you don't rein that in if
you don't figure out what's going to
misplay that then you're done right i
can't tell you if you're done
10 years from now or 50 years from now
but i can tell you you can't roll the
dice with those processes running loose
for very long and have it always come
come up your way so
this is it and you know
this
this is
therefore
this is telling us that our lives
whether we like it or not our lives are
overlapping a moment on which everything
hangs
these are interesting times and we are
we are
stuck with the responsibility of solving
a problem no one has seen before and we
have to get it right
so
you know let's let's recognize that
that's the responsibility that history
has handed us and let's uh let's
shoulder it bravely
oh indeed hey would you mind can i
mention this event that i have coming up
um
so
at peak prosperity for for everybody
listening once a year we hold a virtual
event and uh it's a seminar and brett
will be a headline speaker there as well
we'll have royce white he's an amazing
gentleman pier corey myself marjorie
wildcraft talking about
um uh how to grow food and things like
that but it's really about how to that
we're building it at the title this year
is um surviving the great reset so we we
believe there's a big agenda coming and
there are things we can do
to get ourselves organized around that
and the biggest thing this year is to is
to get connected so right now we
actually have even though the event is
being held next saturday and sunday
which is may 9th and 30th there are
already uh servers open where people who
have signed up for that are chatting and
finding each other because that's that's
what i'm trying to to encourage most
here this year is that connection so
people can find that if you go to peak p
e a k
20 22 dot events
peak 2022
events that's a ur landing page see if
that interests you even though
that's a url suffix
dot com is a it gets you someplace um
dot org it turns out events dot
experience is actually a thing too yes
um all right and i would just like to uh
revisit the point uh early in our
discussion
there's a lot to be said for
pooling our resources
and the discovery that our two channels
uh
have some overlap but much less than you
would imagine in terms of who's paying
attention to each of us and that those
who are hearing this discussion and
thinking wow that's pretty interesting
it would be a great idea
whichever path you traveled to get to
this discussion if you went and followed
the other channel right you chris
martinson on twitter what's your handle
at chris at chris martinson all right
and i am at brett weinstein
brett has one tea
and then on youtube my channel is
brett weinstein your channel
peak prosperity
p-e-a-k cool like you know all right
yep
and peak prosperity is my website too so
so yeah and and uh
uh
whatever i would love to see our our two
groups come together and then other ones
as well because we it's it's really we
got to band together um
i might be wrong but i'm not confused
yeah no this is uh
you're right that's exactly what should
be happening um and let's uh hope it
happens um and well what do you think so
this is our first experiment in a joint
live stream um did we get to dark
prosperity or did we end up at peak
horse
well i i think we're that's good enough
why did the horse side of this
so i see
3.9 000 people chatting away on on my
side of things so that's a that's a
that's good considering it's a saturday
and
people had very little warning that this
was upcoming so
so i think that's um and it just the
number grew the whole time we were
talking all right well fantastic all
those is good signs here um chris it's
been a real pleasure as always and um i
hope we uh we take this prototype and
figure out what to do with it so
we can make some progress and
you know
gather the people who need to gather
[Music]
absolutely and and my only regret that
we couldn't do this live um because i
just can't wait yeah in person in person
is the way to go and uh you and i both
believe that so we will we will do that
as soon as possible
well thank you so much for for setting
this up and and letting us use your
you